[Music]
so kyle have you met any nice girls at
school
do you have a girlfriend
well there is someone great what's your
name does she design her own clothes
like you do
um
hi i'm andy richter coming out to your
family during the holidays is never easy
it can be a delicate process and
sometimes you need a helpful nudge
that's where i come in for just 99.95
i'll come to your holiday dinner and out
you to your family
maybe i can help
kyle's gay everybody
that's right for just 99.95 i'll out you
to your family and for just an
additional 19.95 i'll bring my friend
dion cole to really hammer home the
point
oh my goodness it's dion coleman shut up
thou here
[Music]
you let him be gay but wait there's more
for an additional 9.95 the basic cable
band will come and sing a song about it
and for just a 1.95 more george takei
will come by and congratulate you on
your newfound identity
[Music]
congratulations
and welcome to the wonderful world of
gabe
and if any of you motherfu
i'm gonna come back and
you're
if you're struggling to work up the
nerve to come out to your family this
holiday season let me do it for you get
out of that closet and get on with the
rest of your life i'm gay too
[Music]
[Applause]
that's terrific that's going to help a
lot of people
[Music]
you're gonna make a lot of money